- She's gonna love you.
- Yeah, I hope so (laughs)
- Of course.
- I mean she doesn't really have a choice.
- (woman laughs) Hey!
- Hey
- How are you?
- It's good to finally meet you.
- Hey, good to meet you too.
- Tom, Sara. Sara, Tom
- You guys want something from the bar?
- Yes please
- Yeah sure
- Two vodka sodas
- Yup (giggles)
- Alright
- It's so good to finally
meet your boyfriend
- Oh, but no he's not my boyfriend.
- But didn't you bring him
to your sister's wedding?
- Yeah, I mean we're
friends and we hook up
and we go on dates,
but we're not "dating".
You know, there's no pressure.
- Um, sure yeah.
- Dad, I want you to meet
my really, really special friend, Rachel.
- It's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you
- It's not official.
- No.
- Will you move in with me?
- Oh my God yes of course!
- Yes?
Yes
- Yes!
- Oh my gosh, I can't wait to
have a roommate that I bang.
- Maybe it is your fault for a change.
- Ooh wow! Oh it's my fault?
- Excuse me, can you
and your girlfriend please keep it down?
- Hey, she's not my
girlfriend, she's my bestfriend
who I want to spend the
rest of my life with.
(cheery, elevator music)
(wedding music)
- Tom, it's meant so much to me
that you've been able to keep it so chill
the past four years.
- I can't wait to live this long life
of low commitment hanging out,
only when like work isn't too crazy.
- (Laughs)
- Okay. Well, I now pronounce
you husband and wife.
- (react in disgust)
- We're raising her as friends.
- We live together.
- And are married.
- And share everything in
our lives with each other.
(Christmas music)
(dramatic, piano music)
(woman cries)
- Ms. Jackson I am so sorry for your loss.
- It's fine, we weren't even that serious.
(upbeat drums)